[Musica]
oggi vi voglio raccontare la storia di
questa bambina e di come avesse un sogno
un bellissimo sogno e come questo sogno
non si sia mai realizzato Chi di voi da
bambino ha mai avuto un sogno su
coraggio alzi la mano Chi di voi si
ricorda del sogno di quando era bambino
e di questi quanti di questi sono
riusciti a realizzare il proprio sogno
nessuno Beh si sa I sogni dei bambini
puntano sempre molto troppo in alto c'è
chi vuol diventare era di un castello
chi vuol vincere un anello NBA chi vuol
conquistare la luna questa bambina
voleva soltanto giocare a pallavolo ma
non le bastava lei era esigente lei
voleva andare alle Olimpiadi
ma non le bastava lei voleva andare ad
almeno due Olimpiadi altrimenti sul
sogno non si sarebbe mai realizzato due
Olimpiadi
e il perché di questo strano desiderio
risiedeva in uno scatto che nel 1972 un
fotografo fece sua madre durante la
cerimonia di apertura delle Olimpiadi di
Monaco
Sì anche sua madre Giocava al lavoro è
più precisamente nella nazionale
cecoslovacca e quella dopo messo cosìty
del 68 fu proprio la sua seconda
Olimpiade fotografata stampata
incorniciata e appesa nella casa di
campagna dei suoi nonni che poteva
vedere un paio di volte l'anno
Infatti poco più che neonata questa
bambina aveva seguito sua madre
all'estero in Italia per permettere
appunto di giocare a pallavolo e con lei
era cresciuta lì un pallone e
un'infinità di palestra diverse
nonostante in quella fotografia ci
fossero davvero un sacco di persone Sua
madre era riuscita ad individuare
il punto preciso in cui si trovava in
quel momento e a cerchiare una piccola
testolina sorridente con un grosso
pennarello rosso quel rosso intenso
aveva rapito lo sguardo di quella
bambina e aveva ucciso in lei un fuoco
forte possente il fuoco di un desiderio
di difficile da dimenticare due
Olimpiadi
da mamma di tre bambini oggi rosso bene
i figli vogliono sempre superare i
genitori e non per un semplice spirito
agonistico c'è qualcosa di più qualcosa
di più atavico loro vogliono vincere a
tutti i costi e nella natura delle cose
la nostra generazione deve essere sempre
migliore di quella precedente
ci sta Beh è sempre tutto molto facile
fino a qui no quella bambina ce l'ha nel
sangue è alta figlia di Campioni due
olimpiadi per lei sono una passeggiata
giusto Beh non è esattamente così
Qualche volta ci sono degli ostacoli
insormontabili fra te e i tuoi obiettivi
Monaco 72 non sarebbe stata certo
ricordata per le gesta di sua madre o
per la magia delle Olimpiadi
la fotografia di quella parata fu
preludio di qualcosa di tragico
quell'estate un gruppo di terroristi il
ruppe nel Villaggio Olimpico e prese in
ostaggio alcuni atleti per 20
interminabili le ore 11 di questi
vennero assassinati 11 testoline
sorridenti di quella fotografia
terminarono il loro sogno nel peggiore
dei modi
una brutta storia una di quelle che può
spegnere il fuoco della passione che può
spegnere il desiderio di una bambina non
di questa però per arrivare alle
Olimpiadi dovevo allenarvi ma una
pallavolista in casa sembrava più che
sufficiente la pallavolo è uno sport
noioso mi diceva il basket è molto più
bello Tu giocherai a pallacanestro
Partiamo male anche perché non è facile
è disobbedire a una madre che anche il
tuo supereroe preferito e che da un
giorno all'altro ti ha teletrasportato
in un paese tutto nuovo così da bambina
ho iniziato a giocare a pallacanestro e
comunque continuavo a seguire gli
allenamenti di mia madre e a palleggiare
fare il bagher e schiacciare contro un
muro il basket No non me lo sentivo
proprio cucito addosso Io avevo il mio
sogno da perseguire a discapito di tutto
e di tutti 2 Olimpiadi
proprio come mia madre però lo sanno
tutti una madre un bambino non sa se
nasconderi proprio i segreti è una madre
gli fa vedere Va bene giocherai a
pallavolo Però come dico io e così il
mio supereroe ed era diventato anche il
mio allenatore per 8 intensi anni e la
mia corsa verso L'obiettivo era
cominciata
nel 1984 quando avevo 10 anni vidi su
una rivista specialistica una fotografia
di un atleta di una pallavolista
americana che si era tatuata ai cinque
cerchi in occasione delle Olimpiadi di
Los Angeles venne come folgorata un
giorno anch'io avrei avuto quel
tatuaggio
presto questa determinazione attirò i
principali Club italiani quella ragazza
non aveva particolari doti atletiche
Anzi non saltava proprio ma la tecnica
C'era tutta era quasi perfetta anni mesi
giorni ore a cercare di emulare sua
madre e le campionesse che aveva visto
in palestra le avevano dato delle doti
sorprendenti stava diventando veramente
forte
e così iniziai a vincere i campionati e
a soli 17 anni
vestii la maglia azzurra
ma il mio obiettivo era ancora molto
lontano anche perché la nazionale
italiana non aveva ancora mai
partecipato ad un Olimpiade
la prima vera occasione fu Atlanta 96
Ma la frattura di una tibia della tibia
a sinistra mi impedì di partecipare a
quelle qualificazioni avevo perso un
treno un treno che passava ogni 4 anni
nell'estate del 99 un altro infortunio
Questa volta la spalla destra sembrava
farmi saltare anche le successive
qualificazioni per Sidney 2000
l'intervento andò bene ma i tempi per
tornare in campo erano davvero stretti
nulla che potesse fermarmi però
nell'inverno del 99 per la prima volta
nella storia la nazionale femminile di
pallavolo italiana si qualifica per
Sidney 2000 e in quella squadra C'ero
anch'io
quella bambina era metà del suo sogno
la prima cosa che feci una volta
arrivata al Villaggio Olimpico fu quella
di comprarmi la mia panoramica il mio
post della panoramica delle della
cerimonia di apertura e cerchiare una
piccola testolina sorridente quel giro
di pista davanti a migliaia di persone
fu il momento più esaltante della mia
carriera a prescindere poi da come
andarono le Olimpiadi
quattro anni poi passano velocemente
soprattutto se nel mezzo si arriva a
secondi a un campionato europeo e si
arriva addirittura primi al campionato
del mondo
tutto sembrava andare per il verso
giusto l'obiettivo di quella bambina si
stava era a portata di mano due
Olimpiadi
così L'Italia si qualifica anche per
Atene 2004 grazie anche da riga piccola
che era in squadra nonostante un
ginocchio operato l'anno prima
purtroppo quell'estate fu molto
tormentata e nonostante avessi fatto di
tutto per essere fra le 12 convocate
l'ultimo giorno prima di partire veniva
lasciato a casa
Il sogno di quella bambina andò in
frantumi
come la porta di quella stanza d'albergo
dove mi diedero la notizia
quindi ho fallito non sono riuscita ad
esaudire quel magnifico sogno
Tuttavia ho capito una cosa molto
straordinaria l'importante non era
raggiungere l'obiettivo delle due
Olimpiadi
L'importante è averci provato con tutta
la determinazione che avevo e nonostante
gli ostacoli incontrati durante il
percorso
è per questo che oggi voglio ringraziare
quella bambina perché la sua passione
quella fiamma accesa da un semplice
pennarello su una fotografia mi ha
regalato tantissimo mi ha aperto
infinito opportunità
ho girato il mondo
ho vinto medaglie trofei Coppe
ho fatto esperienze incredibili Come ad
esempio ricevere il cavalierato
direttamente dalle mani del Presidente
della Repubblica
poi questa forma mentis mi ha
accompagnato anche fuori dalla pallavolo
Mi sono laureata nonostante tutti gli
impegni sportivi e familiari sono
diventata massofisioterapista e di
recente ho tenuto anche una cattedra
come insegnante di scienze motorie
Ecco la cosa importante Qualunque sia il
sogno che in cui tu credi
perseguilo con tutto te stesso perché a
prescindere dal tuo desiderio più grande
lavorando sodo e superando gli
innumerevoli ostacoli Che
inevitabilmente ti si presenteranno
davanti otterrai un qualcosa di più
straordinario qualcosa di più importante
del tuo obiettivo iniziale
realizzerai un sogno che nessuna bambina
potrà mai neanche lontanamente
immaginarsi
Grazie a tutti
[Applauso]
[Musica]